actually about what do you believe about
depression do you believe depression is
a real thing I believe that feeling
depressed is real I don't believe
depression as a clinical disease is real
no really correct you don't believe
people can be clearly depressed I think
PTSD is very real unfortunately I have
some friends who suffer from that and I
know that feeling depressed is real I
believe that the number one power you
have against these things are taking
trying to take control of your own mind
and affecting your own life I believe
that it's not healthy to hand over all
your power and believe that depression
is an outside disease that you can't
affect I know that when I've had
difficult periods in my life and also
many of my friends like I've said
something from PTSD and been through
terrible things I've lived a very
difficult life and I know people who
have that the things that made them feel
better is when they woke up and said you
know what I'm not going to allow this to
damage me anymore I'm going to take
responsibility I'm going to get up and
I'm going to fight this as hard as right
and by the way on that I agree so my
favorite speech is the Rocky Balboa okay
so then we agree no we didn't well we
don't agree Pierce you don't hang on on
you've got to let me sure interject when
I don't agree with you right where I
don't agree with you is that there's no
such thing as clinical depression there
absolutely is well it's a proven
scientific medical reality there's a
different argument about have we gone a
bit too soft right in schools and all
the rest of it absolutely yeah well I
think some people moan and whine too
much about their lot in life definitely
okay are we a victimhood society 100
okay is there such a thing as clinical
depression absolutely so and my argument
is that if you actually bracket
everybody who's not guilty depressed and
doesn't have the genuine medical
condition then actually if millions of
people are deemed to have depression the
ones who really need the help don't get
it well that's my point well that can
that that I would agree with you're
right I think it's certainly overused
terms there is such a thing called
depression no I don't and that to me is
a damaging view okay well let me explain
why if someone comes to me and says I'm
clinically depressed or I feel very very
sad I would say the first thing you need
to do is stop accepting the identity of
a clinically depressed person stop
accepting you have no control over this
and what you need to do is stop
identifying that way and let's work
together to try and fight against the
reason an eminent doctor in the world
who would tell you there is no such
thing as clinical depression we would
not tell you that I think I think you're
simply Beyond I think Johann Hari wrote
a book saying exactly that my friend
he's not an imminent doctor no but he is
I said depression wasn't real long ago
and was attacked for it then Johann Hari
wrote a book which is actually because
he wrote a book Proof of me right most
people Johan Hari is a journalist sure
and and my point is that a lot of people
who are clinically depressed are
suffering with something in their life
and if you fix the problem in their life
perhaps they won't feel depressed
anymore but it's not a disease yeah but
Andrew you're not situational Andrew
You're simply wrong
if that's what you believe Pierce that's
what I believe I don't believe in things
that take power away there is not an
eminent doctor in the world would agree
with this I think you know more than
doctors I can't become clinically
depressed
why do you know because I don't believe
it
I can't be haunted by a ghost if I don't
believe in ghosts I'm never going to die
because I don't believe in it it's
ridiculous perhaps but if it allows me
to live a life where I feel happy again
this is that little area where you lose
me no I don't lose you because somebody
with your following so thousands of
people the thousands of people who have
emailed me saying my doctor told me I
was clinically depressed and it's a
disease that I have got in my brain and
I can't be fixed and I started listening
to you and I realized that that's not
the case and I can fix my own life and
you're the only person who has ever
helped me thousands of people have
emailed me that exact email if you think
you are single-handedly curing people of
clinical depression you are living in
Cloud Cuckoo I am reading the emails of
people who I have cured of clinical
depression you're reading emails from
people who have believed you when you
say there isn't such a thing and they've
probably never been diagnosed illegal
depressed they just want to go along
with what Andrew dates says I don't
think so and I think your view of that
is that view is dangerous I I respect
that you think my view is dangerous and
I respect you have the right to view
that if you think that I think that
clinical depression I actually agree do
is massively overdiagnosed I've already
said that PTSD is a very real thing I've
already said I didn't so hang on okay
again you misquoted me I I did not say
clinical depression is massively over
diagnosed I said that people who claim
to be depressed but don't have clinical
depression I think that is massively
overblown right in other words there are
a lot of people who just have a bad day
yeah and declare I've got depression
yeah and I I say well have you been to a
doctor have you been clinically
diagnosed if you have and you have
clinical depression that's one thing but
if you haven't we could probably work on
some mental strength and resilience
skills with it but a clinically
depressed person has a an absolutely
proven medical condition that is beyond
their control not according to me and
many others my friend well look what do
you know about it honestly I know I know
it's a doctor no you're not trained are
you I'm not a doctor a psychiatrist
you're none of those things sure you're
a guy on the make who's done very well
for himself spouting stuff off much of
which I agree with as you've seen in the
interview uh but some of which is
ludicrous and that's one of them it's
not ludicrous it is it's not you said to
me we're in a victim whose Society has
got to stop I'm with you okay at the
moment you try and deny clinical
depression I believe feeling depressed
is real I do not believe it's a disease
that you catch from the sky and you
cannot affect I believe that no matter
what happens I believe you have control
of your own mind and you can fight
against it I believe if you change your
circumstances in your life you may feel
different I'll give you a quick example
I had a guy who emailed me saying was
clinically depressed he was going to
kill himself
I obviously am not a psychiatrist I'm
not a doctor I told him because I
replied to my emails I said have you
been to a psychiatrist he said yes I'm
clinically depressed I've been on these
pills this amount of time I'm on
antidepressants doesn't work I said I
don't know what to say to besides this
and he said he lost his girlfriend
that's why I became clinically depressed
I said listen go to the gym get a
six-pack first once you've got a
six-pack email me again
you still feel like killing yourself I
don't know what else to say to you but
I'd say strong body is a strong mind GO
train
he went he started sending me progress
pictures emailing me him getting better
better shape and eventually got six-pack
he's not a professional bodybuilder and
he said I can't believe I was
considering that I feel so much better
Etc the doctor was telling him he was
clinically depressed and couldn't cure
it he started taking control of his own
life and now he felt better now I'm not
saying it's the case for everybody I'm
just saying my question have you seen
the guy's medical records of course not
I just told you the student is taking
his word for it I am taking the words of
a man who emailed me with a bunch of
medication and specifics you're denying
proven science because one guy writes to
you who you help and you've not seen any
evidence he ever had clinical depression
diagnosed I'm denying the idea that on
the back of it you go on your your rants
in public to tens of millions of people
denying something because this guy
writes students says he had it and you
cured him and I think that's a dangerous
mindset Andrew that's fine that's where
you don't have a responsible view of
your influence over disagree it's very
responsible because I'm saving people's
lives I disagree that if you're dying if
you have if you feel depressed I
disagree that you cannot affect it and
change your life and take control and
fix yourself and feel happier I disagree
with you
I refuse to accept that there are people
out there who cannot become happy
contented individuals I refuse to accept
we live in a world where God has created
people who no matter how hard they work
and how good their life becomes can't be
happy I don't accept that I accept that
the universe is a very giving place and
that God loves all of us and if you try
your best and you work hard you can
become a better person and I also will
argue with you and I'll counter the
point that you sitting here on your
platform telling people they have
clinical depression there's nothing they
can do about it it's far more data okay
well then if they have clinics why do
you misquote no because you're saying
being misquotes no you're saying if
people have clinical depression about it
they go to a doctor and they get
diagnosed and they get help then I would
argue the point that's something
opposite of what you just said I said I
would argue the point that if somebody
has depression of any kind whether it's
clinical whether it exists or not
whether they feel depressed or not
whatever they're taking control of their
life taking personal responsibility and
working hard is always going to be the
positive best thing they can possibly do
for their life going forward
so sitting here saying I don't believe
in clinical depression you don't believe
in depression no I don't I believe that
people can take control and fight
against things right believe in personal
sovereignty right fine good so we agree
no we don't yes we do no be done beers
are on my side you're afraid of being
canceled along with me I said to you
from the start that's all I agree with a
lot of what you say completely so I
thought I'm taking you to task over the
stuff I don't agree with you sure and
I'm just not sure you understand why
it's wrong which is in itself quite
revealing